das spielgerät von auslandsreisen also
wir haben jetzt gebucht für die
herbstferien nach kroatien
und das ist noch nicht risikogebiet wo
wir hinfahren und eigentlich haben wir
vor zu fahren da gibt es kaum infektion
style und er sparen davon nichts sagen
und vertretern macht urlaub in
deutschland was passiert in deutschland
aber es stelle sich inspirierte darüber
nach was neben fahren da sind
kirchenvertreter 400.000 werde ich mein
münchen an coco über 50 guck ich mir
hamburg kommt ständig 70 neue dazu
ersparen hat für mich null euro was dort
abgeht der sollten sich lieber auf
seinen bereich konnten dann ist gut die
wirtschaft kaputt die reifenbranche
kaputt macht alles kaputt oder ist
richtig gut im spiel als richtig dampf
unter dem kessel
tatsächlich macht die politik uns
unseren urlaub kaputt am kempkens nein
also den eindruck habe ich nicht
es ist einfach auch ein bisschen selbst
verantwortung gefragt man muss die
situation selber einschätzen und wie
gesagt wie cool reisewarnungen
risikogebiete sind keine reiseverbote
das war mal so ein bisschen im gespräch
kurz dass man in bestimmten gebieten wo
eben die gefahr sehr hoch ist dass man
sogar ein verbot ausspricht das ist
nicht gekommen
von daher muss das im grunde genommen
jeder selber wissen aber man muss auch
realistisch sehen und ich persönlich bin
der meinung es geht doch nicht darum das
ist doch kein unberechtigter stempel der
da einem land aufgedruckt wird sondern
das wird also ständig nachjustieren das
wird ständig nachgebessert es werden
risikogebiete auch wieder entfallen auch
wieder wenn die situation vor ort besser
wird weil man einfach sagt wir wollen
ganz schnell und ganz konkret und ganz
individuell reagieren und wenn man diese
warnungen in den wind schlagen will wenn
man das eben nicht so sieht okay das ist
jedem selber überlassen aber dann muss
man natürlich auch die konsequenzen
tragen wenn man wiederkommt das ist
einmal diese quarantäne situation die
wir haben und es sind natürlich dann
schwierigkeiten auch mit dem arbeitgeber
wenn ich demnächst sogar trotz negativen
test trotzdem ein paar tage mehr
es ist ja die rede von fünf tagen in
quarantäne muss